VARSHA DATTA: Hey, Everyone.
My name is Varsha Datta, and
I'm a security and compliance
specialist with Google Cloud.
And today I would
like to talk to you
about some of our
newest products
at Google reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Before we go into Google's
reCAPTCHA Enterprise product,
let's talk a little bit
about what a CAPTCHA is
and what it does.
A CAPTCHA as an acronym
for completely automated
public Turing test to tell
computers and humans apart.
It's a type of challenge
response test used in computing
to determine whether a
user is a human or not.
Fairly straightforward, right?
Not really.
There are a lot of nuances
that go into identifying
a real user versus a bot,
and reCAPTCHA Enterprise
is a complete solution
just build to do that
and do this very well.
Let's talk a little bit about
some of these evolving threats
that we've seen in the industry.
Users are constantly
under attack
from credential stuffing,
account takeovers,
and fraud all the time.
And it's really unique compared
to protecting our own employees
within the company,
because we have
less control over
the environment
that our users are in.
But they are as important
to our business.
We've seen that, in
2018 alone, there
were about 20 billion attempted
logins with stolen credentials,
and 29% of those breaches
involved those stolen
credentials.
And an estimated 8% of revenue
for many online businesses
is lost to fraud every year.
The problem is in the
defense of these systems,
especially when you go all the
way to the users' computers,
because it requires a
lot of data and ability
to protect at the client
level in an environment
that you do not control.
As you can imagine,
Google has a lot
of experience in dealing
with fraudulent activities
on our platform.
We have over 1
billion users each
across all of these
nine different products,
and we only learn how to better
protect our users from fraud
over the last few years.
Just for some background,
here at Google
we've been protecting
our own systems
with two spectacular
technologies
over the last decade.
The first is reCAPTCHA, which
defends more than 2 million
websites from fraudulent bots.
And the second one is
Safe Browsing technology,
which defends over
3 billion devices
from phishing and malware.
Let's take a look at
these products in detail.
Some of the more common
types of fraudulent attacks
we see are account takeovers,
synthetic accounts,
false posts, fraudulent
transactions, and money
laundering. reCAPTCHA
Enterprise is
built upon the existing
reCAPTCHA platform
that most of us
are familiar with.
The goal of reCAPTCHA
Enterprise is
to defend against these
various threats, including,
but not limited to scraping,
fraud, and account takeovers.
Now, we want to make it very
difficult for those attackers
to gain access to your
business to consumer services
and use them for
malicious purposes.
Most importantly,
reCAPTCHA Enterprise--
with reCAPTCHA
enterprise, we can
do this while providing
a frictionless experience
to your users and customers.
The product acts
as a barrier that
is placed in front of
your web applications,
where actions can be taken
to stop bots and fraudulent
activities from allow--
and while still
allowing your users in.
Now, let's look at the
evolution of Google's reCAPTCHA
over the years.
It got started with this
squiggly bit of text
that you're trying
to read and enter.
And ask bots got better,
our defenses had to evolve.
And that's why you see these
click boxes and crosswalks
where the challenges have become
a little bit more complex.
And a lot of users actually
have trouble solving these,
and it's not the best
user experience either.
Not only do we face
threats from AI,
but we also face
threats from farming.
A large number of
groups of people
are solving these
challenges for fraudsters,
and now it comes down to
actually distinguishing
the transactions from
fraudulent versus
non-fraudulent transactions,
and not just humans to bots.
The latest version of
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
is essentially a
piece of JavaScript
that interacts with the user
and gives you a risk score
to identify whether the
transaction or the user
interaction was alleged
to make one or not.
So this means no text
boxes and no crosswalks,
and just a snippet
of JavaScript that
sits within your HTML pages.
And there is no user interaction
required for the JavaScript
to start working, which
means no friction from having
to actually solve the challenge.
It's also based on the
user's behavioral analysis
on your backside, rather
than relying on just one form
of signage on your webpage.
So let's take a closer
look at what's included
within reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Now, if you're familiar
with reCAPTCHA v3,
the Enterprise version
includes a lot of--
all of v3 and a lot more.
So it includes an
enhanced risk score
based mechanism which is
based on machine learning,
and is also more
specific to your web site
than just generating bots.
We also provide risk
codes or reason codes
that allow you to
better understand
why we are detecting a certain
behavior as a bot or not.
Now, as a customer, you
also have the ability
to use the annotation API
to provide us feedback
whether or not a
certain risk score
that we provided
was a false positive
versus a false negative.
Now, remember that not
all bots are good or bad.
It really comes down to
understanding your user
behaviors and understanding
what your business needs are.
Now, with reCAPTCHA
Enterprise, we also
have mobile support with mobile
SDKs for Android and iOS.
We also have a new password
leak detection mechanism
that's in early access.
We also have a
two-factor authentication
that can be implemented
for potential fraudsters
to further assert their
identity on your website.
And finally, since we are on
the Google Cloud platform,
we provide SLA and SLO, and
also the standard GCP terms.
Now, since reCAPTCHA
Enterprise actually
looks at the user
behavior, and how
they interact with the
page and synchronously
in the background,
the reCAPTCHA servers
formulate a risk score
based on the anomalies
that we have found
on the website.
Now, with the
Enterprise version,
we are able to provide more
granularity in these risk
scores that range
between 0 to 1--
0 being a bad actor, and
1 being a good actor.
Now, some bots actually
have a bit of a gray area
that we need to provide
more details about.
And that's why the enterprise
version actually provides you
a 10 point score, which allows
our customers to take more
precise decisions
on their website
and how they want to apply these
protections on their website.
Now, as an example,
you almost always
want to have a different level
of protection and security
around your high
value pages like log
in or check out,
rather than a homepage.
Now, let's take a closer look at
some of these risk identifiers
or reason codes.
We're working on adding more
and more of these reason
codes every day, but
here are a few of them.
Now, when a risk
score is returned
that matches any behaviors
in this list and more,
we are providing
additional context
in the form of reason
codes that can assist you
in tuning your responses to your
users and identifying trends.
Now let's do a
high level overview
of how all of these
parts work together.
The page or the
pages are actually
embedded with the
reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Now you can either have
it on one single page
of your website, or
it could be across all
of your different
pages on the website.
The JavaScript will gather
the necessary data required
to process the risk score.
And then that data is passed
along as a tokenized element
and encrypted to the end user.
The predicted web application
will then receive that token
when the user actually
interacts with the website,
and then passes that token
along over to the reCAPTCHA
Enterprise server.
And then once the
reCAPTCHA Enterprise server
is able to collect
all of the parameters,
and analyze it, and
provide a risk score,
it actually sends
that risk score back
to your infrastructure.
Now, based on the
score, you can actually
make a decision
whether or not you want
to allow your user to continue.
And the good news
for current v3 users
is that the implementation is
quite similar across reCAPTCHA
Enterprise and reCAPTCHA v3.
So if you're already a
v3 user, the transition
is pretty much just aligned to
point to a reCAPTCHA Enterprise
endpoint.
So now that we have a risk
score, what kind of action
do we take?
If a high risk
score is returned,
it's more likely that
it's a real user.
And there's-- you wouldn't
want to allow them to continue
their journey on your website.
Now, if it's a low risk score,
depending on the recent code,
you might want to take either
a few types of actions.
You might want to either reject
that user entirely and block
them on your
website, or you might
want to provide a
further challenge,
like a two-factor
authentication,
to allow that user to further
assert their identity.
Either way, you
would want to log
all of these actions
for further analysis.
Now let's look at
some success stories
around reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Spotify was one of
our earlier adopters
of reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
We all know Spotify,
and we love it.
They were disruptors
in the media industry
and transformed how
we listen to music.
Some of the challenges
that Spotify was facing
included detection
of bot traffic
and threats such as
credential stuffing,
and abuse on Spotify's
website and apps.
With reCAPTCHA
Enterprise, they were not
enable to effectively
detect bot traffic,
but also protect and
defend against threats
coming from these bots.
Another one-- another great
example is Empower Illinois.
Empower Illinois is a
state-wide scholarship
granting organization that
was created in 2017 to serve
children of Illinois through the
state's tax credit scholarship
program.
Now, some of the challenges
that they were facing
was fraudulent applications
of machines and credential
stuffing attacks by bots.
With reCAPTCHA
Enterprise, they were
able to accurately
detect bots, and also
create a safe passage
for legitimate users,
and minimize the user
friction on their website.
Now let's take a
look at Web Risk API.
Web Risk API is a
Google Cloud Service
that allows customer web
applications to check URLs
against Google's constantly
updated list of unsafe web
resources.
Web Risk API helps
defend against phishing
links, malware
links, spam links,
amongst other malicious URLs.
It acts as a barrier between
fraudsters and customer website
applications, protecting them
from malicious URLs being
posted on their website.
Let's take a closer
look at Web Risk API.
We all know that URLs contain
unsafe elements like phishing,
malware, and unwanted software.
And it's often impossible to
find this before our users do.
That's why we have Web Risk API,
a new offering from GCP that
enables any company to find
unsafe URLs on their website.
Now, Web Risk includes data on
more than a million unsafe URLs
and users--
and uses Google's Safe
Browsing technology
to defend against
malicious URLs.
Now let's take a look at how
web risk API actually works.
Assume that attackers are
trying to exploit the ACME
reviews by posting unsafe links
onto an even submission feature
page.
To defend their
users and the site
against these kind
of attacks, ACME
decides to use the Web Risk API
to filter all incoming calls
for unsafe content.
ACME needs to
essentially extract
those URLs from the
post and send them
to Web Risk API, where--
and Web Risk API will
be able to identify
whether a URL is unsafe or not.
Then depending on the decision
that Web Risk API makes,
ACME can then decide
to either post or not
post those URLs
on their website.
Now let's look into some
of these threat categories.
Web Risk API also
provides information
on why a certain URL
was deemed malicious
based on some of the mentioned
threat types on the screen
here.
Now, this allows customers to
take a more educated decision
on whether or not to block
these malicious URLs.
Now here's a
remediation response.
For example, let's take a
look at the sample workflow
for Web Risk API.
Once the API returns the
result, if the URL is not
a malicious one,
our customers can
choose to allow the link to be
then utilized on their website.
But if the URL is malicious,
their customer then--
the customer can either
decide to block the access
to the website entirely by using
something like a web proxy,
or flag the post as
a malicious pose,
or even block the post
entirely from being
submitted on the website.
Either way, logging
these activities
is always a good
practice to allow scope
for future analysis.
Now that you've heard
all the awesomeness
about reCAPTCHA Enterprise
and Web Risk API,
it's time to take action.
If you're facing
any issues regarding
your fraudulent
activities on the website,
we can help you with it.
Please reach out
at cloud.google.com
/recaptchaenterprise and
cloud.google.com/webrisk.
And get in touch with our
sales and technical teams
to help protect your website.
Thank you for tuning in today.